une tête des jambes une main de fer
Astrid Guillard vous êtes secrétaire
général du Comité national olympique
sportif français vous êtes ingénieur en
aérospatial à Arian espace vous êtes
vicechampionne olympique desrim
qu'est-ce qui compte le plus à stred
pour vous définir dans ce CV d'être bien
avec moi-même d'être aligné entre ce que
je mais comment on aligne tout ça j'ai
jamais
il paraît que choisir c'est renoncer et
c'est vrai que bah est-ce que choisir
c'est pas préférer plutôt que renoncer
euh j'avais plusieurs passions plusieurs
préférences mais disons que je les ai
pas mis au même moment c'est ce
cadencement cette intelligence dans le
fait de se dire ne pas tout faire en
même temps on risque de tout planter h
je pense qu'il m'a permis de de ne pas
avoir à préférer l'un ou l'autre mais
plutôt l'un après l'autre ou d'avoir
cette espèce d'équilibre typiquement
entre les études d'abord à l'école
d'ingénieur la prépa euh bien sûr
l'équipe de France olympique ensuite mon
métier d'ingénieur à arien group euh
avec le temps partiel avec cette
intelligence de se dire il y aura des
moments où je serai à temps plein
d'autres à temps partiel et puis il y a
des parfois des moments où je serai
totalement dédié à mes entraînements euh
à mes compétitions et surtout à la au
temps de préparation qualification
olympique et Jeux Olympiques parce que
on le sait bien pour atteindre le très
haut niveau ça demande une expertise et
qui dit expertise dit et des heures et
des heures au compteur à s'entraîner à
répéter parfois pour qu'après le geste
il se fasse avec fluidité en automatisme
alors on va parler de ce geste on va
parler de ce sport si particulier euh
mais d'abord vous avez arrêté vous ça y
est c'est fini le haut niveau c'est
derrière vous euh ça va oui ça va vous
manque pas euh le l'escrim me manque pas
du tout alors après j'avais commencé à 5
ans et je me suis arrêté à 38 ans donc
prof j'ai bien profité de mon sport et
puis je dois admettre que sur la fin de
carrière il y avait quand même le corps
qui fatigué ouais des blessures au genou
au coude des opérations il faut revenir
on récupère moins
bien le doute bien sûr parce que quand
on vieillit bah ça veut dire aussi ça
c'est la la la loi de la jungle he le
sport de haut niveau quand on vieillit
ça veut dire qu'il y a des jeunes aussi
qui arrive alors c'est pas que dans le
haut niveau c'est en général le cycle de
la vi nous le temps est plus court on
est à la retraite beaucoup plus tôt que
dans ma vie professionnelle donc bien
sûr on est en permaintenance en pleine
remise en question et puis quelque part
moi j'avais toujours le le le côté feu
vert feu rouge je me suis toujours levé
le matin je partais à l'entraînement
c'était complètement naturel c'était
même une évidence ou ne pas y aller me
coûter et puis à un moment donné je
sentais que il fallait que j'aille
chercher parfois cette motivation alors
heureusement il y avait les jeux il y
avait en plus le CO qui avait remis mon
épreuve par équipe alors qu'il l'avait
enlevé au moment des des jeux de r 201
extrémist de cette aventure olympique à
Tokyo ouais absolument parce que je me
suis blessée sur cette dernière
olympiade et c'est vrai que c'est c'est
dur il faut aller chercher des
ressources il faut s'entourer
différemment parce que quand on est en
fin de
carrière c'est pas comme une petite
jeune qui arrive en équipe de France où
l'entraîneur peut appuyer sur n'importe
quel bouton ça fait progresser l'athlète
ouais quand on arrive dans un niveau
d'expertise c'est des petits détails qui
vont faire la différence donc ça veut
dire qu'il faut tout individualiser il
faut aller chercher ce qui n'existe pas
pour un collectif parce que il faut
faire du sur hm hm et donc je suis allé
m'entouré de nouvelles spécialités d'une
danseuse d'une chorégraphe d'une
chercheuse en neurosciences bien sûr
j'ai travaillé avec des avec des
professionnels de la réathlétisation
pour prendre en compte ce corps qui
était malgré tout vieillissant il était
performant mais vieillissant et si je
m'entraînais comme une petite jeune
j'allais tout casser ouais et donc c'est
c'est c'est comme ça qu'on arrive
finalement à aller chercher même sur une
on va dire une fin de carrière de la
performance c'est un sport qu'on connaît
pas très bien lesesrim qu'on découvre et
pour lequel on vibre en gros tous les 4
ans en France parce que c'est un sport
olympique et la France a une grande
école d'escrim regardez cette photo on
se rend pas compte de ce dont vous venez
de parler c'est-à-dire du côté
athlétique performant voire
artistique qu'est et qu'exige lesescrim
d'abord je voudrais que vous nous
parliez de votre arme vous c'est le
fleuret c'est quoi la différence et
pourquoi cette arme là plus que les deux
autres alors pourquoi cette arme là je
pense que c'est une histoire de hasard
d'ailleurs pourquoi ce sport là plus
qu'un autre c'est un has ça vous avez
pas d'explication bah l'explication elle
est purement logistique hein mon en
avait un à côté de chez vous de clubs
exactement exactement mon club près de
chez moi c'était un club d'escrime mon
grand frère bris champion olympique lui
avait choisi ce sport parce qu'il avait
entendu du bruit il avait été voir et ça
lui avait plu et pour ma mère tout
simplement mettre les deux enfants au
même sport sur les mêmesau donc voilà
l'histoire c'est pas un compte de fait
c'est une histoire praticopratique d'une
maman qui met les de deux enf mais
d'accord mais il se trouve que l'un et
l'autre vous y avez découvert quelque
chose d'unique ex épanoui parce qu'en
fait c'est à la fois une un sport qui a
une dimension physique et énergétique
très forte comment ça se manifeste on
est tout le temps en flexion regardez là
avant à rien on est comme sur des
ressorts pour aller chercher une
mobilité avant au moment d'attaquer
également une mobilité arrière c'est
quand même un de seul des rares sports
où on performe vers l'arrière le
squelette n'est pas fait pour ouais et
donc on est tout le temps en rebond avec
cette flexion et on va attaquer donc
d'un coup on va choisir prendre la
décision d'attaquer et donc
explosivité puiss puissance explosivité
précision donc tout ça fait que le le
corps est en action et le C le cerveau
il pétille parce Queen même temps on est
en train de jouer avec l'autre c'est un
sport d'opposition c'est un sport de
dialogue on va dire même si on on a
envie d'imposer sa décision à l'autre et
et ça ça fait qu'on est tout le temps
avec ses sens en alerte pour trouver le
bon moment pour justement déclencher son
action et donc c'est la tête et les
jambes et à la fois la dépense
énergétique moi j'ai beaucoup d'énergie
donc j'avais besoin quand même de
quelque chose de ez ça là ça c'est face
à votre adversaire c'est en c'est cette
fameuse finale face à la à la Russie euh
on voit votre adversaire il faut faire
preuve en plus d'une souplesse hors
norme alors pour le coup la rus c'est
beaucoup plus souple que moi sur cette
photo faites pas ça vous non je ne le
fais pas vous faisz ce qui est génial
avec mon sport c'est que quels que
soient ses habilités physiques ses
aptitudes physiques on peut créer
l'escrime qui va autour de ça il y a pas
un modèle il y a pas un moule et
absolument on peut êre grand on peut
être petit on peut être très fin on peut
être très élastique on peut être très
explosif très puissant peu importe tu
vas inventer l'escrime qui te correspond
et je crois que c'est aussi ça la magie
de l'escrim française c'est pour ça
qu'on a une très belle école d'escrim
c'est que on part de ce qui est la
personne son caractère aussi et j'en
reviens à votre première question sur la
différence des armres nous on a cette
curasse électrique qui est uniquement
sur le Tron donc vous voyez que la tête
les bras et les jambes c'est en blanc
c'est non valable si on a on touche là
on ne touchera pas ça compte pas il faut
extrême beaucoup de précision beaucoup
coup de concentration pour loger le
petit bout de sa pointe sur cette
cuurasse électrique qui est clairement
en train de bouger clairement hostile
parce que l'adversaire a pas l'intention
de se faire toucher à la différence
d'une autre arme comme l'épée où là on
est tout en blanc et on peut toucher
absolument n'importe où et c'est le
premier qui touche quel point alors le
troisème c'est le sabre alors qu'au
fleurer il faut avoir la priorité faut
avoir la notion d'attaquant donc l'épée
l'arme des chevaliers hein je te touche
tes morts et et le sabre l'arme des
cavaliers donc là on va trancher hein
parce qu'on sent bien qu'à cheval c'est
beaucoup plus difficile de piquer c'est
beaucoup plus simple de tranch mais on
tranche que le haut du corps parce que
en bas il y a quoi il y a la tête de son
cheval et donc dans ce CASL ça ça marche
beaucoup moins bien et donc vous vous
avez commencé avec le fleuret et vous
l'avez gardé je l'ai gardé parce que
c'est une arme qui déjà c'était l'arme
qui était pratiquée dans mon club du
vaisiné là où où j'ai commencé et puis
c'était à nouveau une arme qui était que
je trouve très complète il y a à la fois
la notion de tactique il y a la dépense
énergétique d'un d'un sport de de
convention avec la notion d'attaquant un
moment donné la prise de risque compte
aussi la pression qu'on peut mettre à
son adversaire et et moi ça me plaisait
ce ce ce côté très très complet de mon
sport et voilà et donc j'en ai jamais
changer et quand je me suis amusé
parfois à faire de l'épée j'ai vu que ça
correspondait pas à mon caractère très
offensif moi j'aime j'aime la prise de
risque j'aime prendre des initiatives et
le le fleurer comme le sabre permettre à
ce genre de caractère de se révéler et
puis il y a un truc chez les escrimeur
c'est qu'on effectivement on vous voit
pas mais qu'est-ce que vous êtes bavard
on vous entend crier et surtout les
victoires donneent un spectacle toujours
le même d'explosion de joie comme si
cette concentration qui est nécessaire
pendant le combat à un moment donné on
lâche tout on a tout souvenir de ces
escrimeurs et ces escrimeuses qui
remportent un combat et un duel est-ce
que vous aussi ce moment-là cette
cocotte au moment où vous gagnez enfin
ce duel ça disait quelque chose de vous
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne retrouve
pas nulle part ailleurs ça ça manque
ouais ce moment o on est tellement
intense cette intensité dans la présence
qu'on a sur la piste face à son
adversaire on expulse et c'est pas
forcément que la victoire parfois c'est
que la touche la touche symboliser à
l'arbitre son adversaire ça sort tout
seul ça ça veut dire qu'on est
pleinement ici maintenant avec son
adversaire dans ce qu'on sait faire dans
ce qu'on sait le mieux faire ça je le
retrouve pas ouais et ça ça me
manque déch fa faire un petit deil de ça
bien sûr qu'il faut faire un petit deil
bien sûr que c'est long bien sûr que des
fois encore quand je m'entends dire
j'étais escrimeuse il y a un petit
pincement mais il y a tellement d'autres
choses à découvrir dans la vie on va en
parler de cette vie multiple en plus qui
est la vôre il y a une relation sur
laquelle j'aimerais bien vous entendre
il y a l'escrimeur et il y a son maître
d'armes c'est pas un coach c'est pas un
entraîneur on dit un maître d'armes
racontez-nous ce qu'est un maître
d'armes un maître d'arme c'est l'anceign
an c'est celui qui nous apprend bien sûr
à manier les armes à en avoir une
certaine forme de
maîtrise mais c'est aussi celui qui
transmet les valeurs les valeurs
d'honneur les valeurs le code moral on
va dire d'un sport de combat et
l'escrime est un sport de combat bien
sûr un sport de combat qui se pratique à
distance à distance des deux armes mais
bien sûr que les le code éthique le code
moral des sports de combat se retrouve
aussi en escrime et donc c'est à la fois
un enseignant de larme mais c'est aussi
un éducateur et ça je pense que c'est
quelque chose de très très fort parce
qu'on grandit aussi grâce à y a un qui
vous a marqué bien sûr celui qui m'a mis
le fleuret dans la main celui qui m'a
amené à mes premières victoires je me
souviens encore à la fête des jeunes la
fête des jeunes c'est espèce de
championnat de France minime on est des
bébés mais il y a du monde on sent que
c'est important et puis voilà on a sa
première médaille qui compte on est
championne de France et là on se
projette c'est à ce moment-là que vous
avez compris que vous allez être vous
aviez une carrière dans ce sport vous
l'aviez pressenti avant on comprend
jamais totalement on le souhaite là ça
s'allume et puis on a des référents moi
j'avais Lionel plumik Franck Boidin les
olympiqu d'Atlanta ils deviendront mes
coachs aussi 15 ans plus tard donc ça
aussi c'est tout un symbole d'une
transmission mais je me suis jamais moi
c'est pas l'histoire des Sir William ça
me dire très petite je vais être
championne ouais au début moi j'ai mes
copines je vais au club des scam parce
que je me marre parce que je prends du
plaisir parce que j'ai m j'ai mes
copines j'ai mes doigts de la main qui
le sont toujours aujourd'hui ou les les
les amis que je me suis fait club des
SCM c'est toujours mes meilleurs amis
aujourd'hui toujours à mes côtés parce
que ça crée c'est des valeurs de loyauté
de solidarité infaillibl c'est on
apprend à grandir ensemble quand on moi
je me souviens je suis une enfant plutôt
dynamique mais j'ai pas confiance en moi
et le sport m'ais heureusement donc
parce que quelle carrière alors sinon
vous auriez fait non mais et et c'est
vrai que j'ai appris à me connaître
l'escrim pour moi ça a été un prétexte
de partir à ma rencontre je me suis pas
dit je veux être championne c'est venu
au fur et à mesure j'ai vu que j'avais
du talent j'ai vu que je gagnais j'ai
pris de plaisir à la gagne h ça oui je
peux pas lier mais ça s'est construit
mais ça a révélé quelque chose chez vous
en fait je suis une gagneuse une
compétitriceoui je peux gagner je je je
peux me révéler je peux exister je peux
prendre ma place ça c'est sûr et puis je
peux être fier de moi ouais la première
fois que j'ai eu mon survette équipe de
France alors mais c'est magnifique mais
c'est magnifique de la même façon que et
c'est marrant parce qu'au moment où j'ai
cette médaille P dans la main je
m'aperçois du chemin parcouru ouais et
je mets du temps à me l'approprier cette
médaille parce que on on en rêve mais on
y passe des nuits en parce que je veux
pas remener le couteau dans la PL mais
il y avait eu une marche de trop en 2012
vous finissez 4e voilà c'est celle que
on l'a pas ce podium ce truc là c'est
une cicatrice il est pas passé c'est une
cicatrice et c'est pour ça que
l'histoire se termine bien d'ailleurs le
c'est quasiment la même équipe en 2012
Anita Blas isatibus Pauline Ranvier
vient nous compléter effectivement au
moment des Jeux de Tokyo mais ça c'est
aussi une histoire voilà je trouve que
c'est la belle histoire du fleur et d'â
je tiens à le dire moi je viens d'une
arme où on avait même pas le droit de
faire les Jeux mondiaux universitaires
les Universiades parce que soi-disant on
était pas assez bonne h je viens d'une
arme où on était méprisé où on ne
pouvait pas où on était entraîneur
national du fleur et d'ame parce qu'on
avait pas réussi à voir les
hommes je viens d'une arme où
oui on nous avait même mis un entraîneur
d'épée alors qu'on faisait du fleuret on
sent qu'il y a une espèce de petite
revanche à travers tout ça pour vous les
filles oui en tout cas je suis fière
aujourd'hui que le fleur et d'AM soit
potentiellement l'arme qui peut ramener
deux fois leur olympique aux Jeux
olympiques de Paris elles sont là vos
copines c'était donc ce fameux
podium de de Tokyo l'escrime vous l'avez
dit c'était un club à côté de chez vous
mais ça une image pas très populaire euh
dans certains quartiers les enfants ils
pensent même pas à aller faire de
l'escrit est-ce qu'aujourd'hui à la
place qui est la vôtre je l'ai dit vous
êtes secrétaire général du du Comité
national olympique et sportif français
le CNOSF c'est aussi le
rôle de personnalité comme vous de d'une
certaine manière casser les barrières et
de dire à des enfants qui spontanément
vont aller faire du foot ou de la boxe
par exemple de casser les stéréotypes
vous pouvez faire du golf vous pouvez
faire de l'escrime vous pouvez faire du
tennis est-ce que ça aussi c'est c'est
espèce de petite bourgeoisie du sport
vous les comprenez c'est vrai que le
matériel peut être un frein à la
pratique mais ce matériel aujourd'hui il
est prêté en CL et ça important de le
dire parce que pour des parents c'est
très effrayant absolument et donc on n
pas besoin d'arriver avec l'enfant qui a
déjà son masque son Fleuré et sa tenue
blanche et puis on a c'est un petit côté
aristocratique vous le disiez c'est les
combats c'est les duels comme comme
avant entre guillemets or ça peut être
un sport populaire bien sûr Anita blaz
qui est ma coéquipière vicechampionne
olympique à mes côtés vient du club
d'aubervillier il y a énormément de
clubs dans certains quartiers
prioritaires des politiques de la ville
par contre c'est toujours pareil il faut
des créneaux il faut des salles il faut
des gymnases et il faut des éducateurs
et et donc ça passe par bah les brevets
d'état ça passe par une sensibilisation
donc ça c'est extrêmement important et
puis après on fera rien sans
infrastructure mais pour ça il faut
avoir envie av de de de s'inscrire dans
cette logique là et d'avoir le sentiment
d'être un peu reconnu vous me voyez
venir la
reconnaissance des éducateurs la
reconnaissance des bénévoles dans un
pays comme le nôtre elle est pas ouf
Astrid Guer on va pas se raconter
d'histoire il y a un problème de
considération voilà c'est le terme pour
tous ces gens qui font tenir le sport
français est-ce que vous vous sentez
aujourd'hui encore une fois au poste qui
est le vôtre avec toute les commissions
d'athlètes et et aussi les la
gouvernance du sport français cette
responsabilité là envers eux absolument
le sport français tient parce que 3,5
million de bénévoles le font vivre au
quotidien dans les clubs dans
l'organisation de compétition parce que
c'est eux qui emmènent la jeunesse en
déplacement ouis donc on leur doit qui
lav les maillots qui font les gâteaux
lorsqu'il y a les les carmesses ex
exactement et donc on leur doit cette
reconnaissance on doit leur permettre de
se former eux aussi je sais qu' il a il
y a des dispositifs qui existent pour
valoriser ces heures et activer des
droits à la formation mais qui sont
sous-utilisés parce que parfois trop
complexes
administrativement pas assez connu
absolument donc il faut il y a une forme
de de simplification à à permettre
justement pour que les bénévoles
accèdent à leurs droit tout simplement
et en plus à leur faire connaître et et
ça c'est vrai que c'est des travaux qui
sont en cours il faut le dire avec le
ministère des sports et des Jeux
Olympiques et paralympiqu donc c'est en
cours pour pouvoir valoriser cette
filière qui est indispensable le sport
fédéré mourra si on ne valorise pas les
bénévoles qui le
fontstème bien sûr mais du coup on
passera à quoi du sport marchand et le
sport marchand à un moment donné quand
on n'a pas les moyens c'est aussi une
difficulté la vie associative elle a de
ça de beau que c'est le brassage social
c'est l'émancipation pour tous à travers
le sport et ça il faut absolument pas le
casser moi j'oppose pas les deux mais je
dis qu'il faut pas un seul modèle parce
que le sport il doit être accessible au
plus grand nombre quel que soi ses
revenu quel que soit son milieu social
et et ça c'est les clubs c'est les
structures associatives fédérées qui le
permettre une question quand même sur la
place du sport en France parce que c'est
un Pelier en fait à ce que nous venons
de dire est-ce que vous avez eu le
sentiment d'être reconnu à votre juste
valeur compte tenu de votre parcours en
tant qu'athlète de haut niveau c'est
c'est vrai que la culture sportive en
France on oppose toujours les deux la
tête et les jambes quoi non alors que
vous vous êtes les deux on l'a
dit pas que moi un de niveau est
extrêmement intelligent il a une
intelligence de jeu il a une
intelligence de son sport il a une
maturité il a une intelligence
situationnelle et bah pourquoi on y
arrive pas pourquoi par rapport à nos
pays des nos voisins il s'agit pas
d'aller aux États-Unis ne serait-ce que
nos voisins les Allemands les Italiens
les Espagnols évidemment les
Britanniques pourquoi on est si loin ça
prend un peu temps ça pense ça passe
certainement par l'école euh je pense la
pratique du sport à l'école le
reconnaître comme une vraie matière une
matière pédagogique d'autant qu'on on
grâce au sport on développe pas que des
habilités physiques je parlais tout à
l'heure de concentration h
de de de de d'habilité d'aptitude
cognitive mais ça le sport permet de les
développer la logique la tactique
exactement il y a pas que les maths la
tactique évidemment SP c'est très et
donc c'est nié tout un pan de
développement cognitif que permet le
sport en plus des compéten motrices je
veux dire c'est pas pour rien que les
grandes universités américaines
reconnaissent les athlètes qui font des
compétition à haut niveau comme des
parcours d'excellencesolument on doit
reconnaître ça c'est une discrimination
positive on ob
est très bon en ma ou en langue
absolument il y a tellement de
compétences transférables entre ce qu'on
vit en tant que sportif de haut niveau
et ce qu'on va mettre ensuite à profit
au cours d'une carrière professionnelle
moi je le vois bien et ayant vécu en
parallèle ces deux mondes entre Arian
Group et puis l'équipe de France
olympique c'est incroyable la
concentration même l'intuition SP
qu'est-ce que le sport vous vous apporte
quand vous êtes dans vos équipes avec à
diriger vos équipes à r alors la
capacité dans l'instant à être
pleinement concentré évidemment la
gestion du stress ça c'est une évidence
je veux dire c'est on a été suffisamment
stressé quand on monte sur la piste des
Jeux Olympiques bon je pense que là la
dose de stress bon voilà on sait faire
bon un lancement d'Aran 5 ou d'Aran 6
c'est stressant aussi c'est certain
c'est Max ok eu en plus on est un peu
moins moteur hein une fois que la
séquence finale est lancée alors qu' Mo
au moins quand j'allais monfleurer
j'étais pleinement actrice pour moi il y
a une notion qui est essentielle c'est
la notion
d'intuition l'intuition c'est une forme
d'intelligence c'est une intelligence
qui peut se baser sur la somme des
expériences qu'on a déjà vécu quand on
on s'entraîne pour les Jeux Olympiques
on répète on s'entraîne des heures et
des heures 5 à 6 fois par semaine je
veux dire c'est c'est plus de 30 HE 35
heures d'entraînement par semaine et
puis on va se confronter à des tonnes de
situations tactiques qui vont faire que
quand ça va se présenter au lors de la
compétition face à son adversaire on
saura on n' pas besoin de conscientiser
on n pas besoin de tout rationaliser on
a rationalisé ma avant quand on est à
l'entraînement le jour J sur la piste
c'est là il y a pas besoin de savoir où
c'est c'est stocké quelque part et on a
juste à laisser aller ce qu'on sait déjà
ça c'est ce qu'on appelle l'intuition
mais l'intuition c'est une forme de
connaissance c'est une intelligence
qu'on peut utiliser aussi dans sa vie
professionnelle
par inelligence
situationé à l'expérience exactement et
c'est pas lié à une logique c'est pas
rationnel c'est pas cartésien comme on
l'AIM et qui est rassurant c'est ce
qu'on appelle les experts simplement
dans le monde de l'entreprise exactement
euh je l'ai dit vous êtes donc Ingénieur
vous êtes une sportive de haut niveau
vous dirigez une partie du du du Comité
national olympique français et puis vous
vous êtes dit à un moment il me manque
un truc et je vais faire un enfant et
vous l'avez dit cet enfant vous l'avez
fait tard mais vous aviez congelé
vososites ça ce combat là don dont on
parle assez peu en
fait c'est aussi le vôtre
Astrid oui toujours cette sur cette
notion de choix à tout faire en même
temps avoir le choix
absolument alors il se trouve que moi je
viens d'une génération d'athlètes
ou quand j'ai commencé à être en équipe
de France dans les années 2000 ça ne se
faisait pas ouais d'être maman en
carrière sauf quelques exceptions et je
suis obligé de citer l'UR flesselle bien
s numéro une
de l'épé dame en son temps h et qui
avait réussi à avoir un système
professionnel c'était la seule athlète
professionnelle de l'escrim dans les
années 2000 pour le reste ça ne se
faisait pas et si on commençait à penser
maternité très rapidement le raccourci
était fait dire bon elle est passée à
autre chose elle est plus dedans elle
est plus motivée et dans un système
ultra concurrentiel on cède sa place et
donc on la perd potentiellement et donc
c'est vrai qu' et puis il y a un âge on
va se le dire où on récupère moins bien
voilà on récupère moins bien
entraînement et donc on récupère moins
bien d'une grossesse aussi donc moi je
viens d'une génération où ça ne se
faisait pas dans mes jeunes années et il
y a eu un moment où c'était un petit peu
trop tard à 35 ans se dire je vais
réussir à faire un bébé à revenir à
m'entraîner à me qualifier parce que
j'étais plus numéro une incontesté le
système ne pouvait pas me garantir qu'on
allait mettre en place les moyens et que
j'allais réussir à me qualifier et donc
la prise de risque elle était beaucoup
trop importante par contre il y avait
une autre prise de risque qui était
encore moins concevable c'était de se
dire que pour une médaille olympique
j'allais mettre en péril un projet
familial un un un projet de maternité
que je ressentais au fond de moi aussi
fortement que je ressentais l'envie de
de de de revenir avec une médaille au
jeu et donc à un moment donné en plus il
y a le report des jeux en 2020 un an de
plus en de carrière c annta incroyable
pour n c'était l'année de trop presque
ça aurait pu c'était l'année de trop de
toute façon mais ça aurait été encore
pire si je n'avais pas congelé mes vite
parce que là j'avais un choix cornélien
à faire un choix absurde de dire tu
choisis entre une médaille olympique
hypothétiqueune fois qu'on l'a on peut
dire l'oire est belle je connais la fin
de l'histoire mais sur le coup on n'est
pas encore qualifié et une médaille
olympique on sait à quoi ça tient le
jour J il peut se passer énormément de
choses tout le monde la mérite hein déta
c'est pas une question de mérite la
médaille olympique hein très clairement
c'est des détails aussi de jourg donc il
y avait ça et puis un enfant mais c'est
c'est une question qui ne se pose pas
non c'est incompable ch atroce et en
fait ce qui s'est dé passé c'est
qu'effectivement en 2018 donc je je me
blesse au genou et je sais pas pourquoi
c'est mon caractère ça toujours de me
dire quand il t'arrive quelque chose
fais en une opportunité h et ça c'est
vraiment quelque chose que je cherche
l'opportunité derrière la contrainte et
donc là j'étais contrainte obligée de m'
d'être opérée du genou et donc quelque
part avec du temps devant moi et je me
suis dit bah est-ce que ce serait pas le
moment je me suis souvenu d'une parole
d'une amie qui m'avait parlé de ça il y
a 10 ans j'en avais rien fait puis c'est
revenu ça émergé et quelque part ça a
été
ma mon mon gage de sérénité mon gage de
sérénité parce que je savais que j'avais
X en banque et que je pour pourrais
toujours y faire appel si besoin et
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est important
que les athlètes le sachent qu'il a
cette possibilité de pouvoir avoir cette
sécurité en anticipant les choses et
d'avoir ces ovocytes qu'on peut toujours
décongeler au moment où sera prête parce
que c'est en plus c'est pareil hein
faire un enfant en carrière encore
faut-il avoir trouvé la bonne personne
bien évidemment hein on fait certaineses
femmes et veulent faire ens se mais si
c'est un projet qu'on souhaite
construire à deux parce que c'est pas
facile d'être une famille monoparentale
et ben il faut être bien accompagné hein
c'est quand même mieux pour l'enfant à
naître aussi et donc il y a plein de
raisons qui peuvent faire qu'on a envie
de décaler ou d'attendre pour avoir un
projet de maternité un projet familial
et donc ça c'est quelque chose qu' j'ai
j'ai envie que les athlètes sachent
qu'elles peuvent utiliser ce droit en
plus aujourd'hui c'est grâce à la loi de
bioéthique c'est possible en France
c'est remboursé par la Sécurité sociale
il faut que ça reste un choix j'insiste
là-dessus parce que il faut pas que ce
soit imposé faut pas que d'un coup les
entraîneurs se disent ah bah tu peux
coner ces donc tu décales ex parce qu'
aujourd'hui il y a des athlètes alors
vous l'avez dit elles sont numéro 1 dans
leur sport on pense à Estelle mosly on
pense à Clariss benénou on pense à
certaines joueuses de l'équipe de France
de football de handes ou de basket elles
font des enfants pendant leur carrière
donc contrairement à la génération
d'Avan c'est possible mais on offre
aussi le choix à cette même génération
jeune tu peux aussi attendre mais
tranquilise-toi l'esprit si jamais un
jour tu veux ce sera possible en fait
votre vie ça a toujours été le champ des
possible ne jamais fermer les possibles
c'est exactement pour ça que je disais
que je j'ai j'ai choisi de ne pas
choisir j'aime que mon champ des
possiblees soit le plus large possible
et c'est à moi de faire mes choix de
créer les conditions pour rendre les
choses possibles j'aime être comme ça
c'est pour ça que mais ça me fait
plaisir et parce que je trouve que la
vie elle est il y a tellement de
possibilités dans une vie c'est
incroyable c'est vrai que j'ai fermé
l'épisode de astrrid Guillard esrimeuse
olympique mais il y a tellement de
choses devant moi à explorer j'ai
tellement de façons de pouvoir me
redécouvrir me réinventer que c'est
c'est une chance incroyable quoi et moi
j'aime ça par contre ce que je n'aime
pas c'est qu'on choisisse pour nous je
n'aime pas qu'on décide ce qui est bon
pour un athlète l'athlète c'est on est
intelligent laissez-nous le choix et on
saura ce qui est bon pour nous ce qui
est bon pour notre performance sport
français réjouissez-vous d'avoir Astrid
Guillard avec vous merci merci Nathalie